en qué consiste este proyecto de ley y
por qué los opositores consideran que se
van a restringir las libertades civiles
raúl tres años lo que hay que decir
primero es que son 32 artículos lo que
es polémico en este momento son tres
artículos específicamente la ley es para
reformar el sistema policía y el sistema
de seguridad en francia dado que las
cosas han cambiado con temas de
atentados con el tema de lo que está
pasando con la crisis sanitaria entonces
hay que darle más como hacían fuerza a
la policía pero no más derechos también
vale te dos deberes
entonces el artículo 24 que restringe la
difusión no la toma de imágenes de la
policía es para evitar que esas imágenes
circulan en las redes social y aquí haya
interpretación entonces en hoy en día
vemos que la manifestación hay de todo
no solamente están gente de los derechos
humanos porque vemos en la primera vez
que por ejemplo amnistía internacional
llamó a justamente a esas
manifestaciones pero también hay otras
personas por derecho a la cultura
entonces se está mezclando un poquito
varios temas la idea es que esta ley
está mal entendida hasta por la policía
la policía piensa que no le se les puede
firmar si todavía se puede afirmar los
lo que hay que hacer es que justamente
no se puede una sin moderación sin
control con sesgo empezar a publicar
esas fotografías y esas imágenes de la
policía también está el artículo 20 y 22
que es con la utilización de cámaras de
vigilancia y el tema de drones que la
policía estaba utilizando últimamente
los drones pero no había una legislación
específica y eso va a permitir
justamente como hacía más legalizar la
utilización de drones en manifestación y
en otros ambientes pero lo que hay que
ver también esta ley está trabajando
sobre el tema de la seguridad privada
sabemos que para los grandes eventos por
ejemplo vamos a recibir dentro de poco
la copa mundial mundo de rugby va a
estar los juegos olímpicos se están
contratando muchos subcontratistas y ahí
la va a ser mucho más drástico y mucho
más control que va a tener el estado y
los que los están contratando la
subcontratación va a ser mucho más
difícil ciencia que esta ley permite
justamente poner una policía del siglo
21 podemos decir a pesar de una mala
interpretación y el problema es también
se ha politizado tremendamente esta ley
no está votada fue examinada en primer
ronda con la asamblea nacional va a ir
al senado y después está el consejo
constitucional que va a verificar con la
constitución francesa que ya vida tiene
estar ahí pero como digo en este momento
son tres artículos de los 32 que crean
grandes políticas